what is up
babies welcome to another episode of get
close i am your co-host geo and i'm bart
and today we have a very special guest
my brother a family member of mine um
i'm so stoked to have you here matt
vincent if you don't know who matt
vinson is you've been like you need to
know who this dude is i absolutely love
your story
um because you were just like okay so
you're you started off you're from
louisiana um you got a scholarship to
lsu for what track and field so went to
on a track and field scholarship to
throw uh shot put discus and hammer at
lsu [ __ ] stud okay so then that
slowly trickles and translates to you
now competing in what so
after that i go through finishing
college um and then getting back into
lifting a couple years after and uh
getting into strong man and then finding
a local group that's doing that so this
is like
7
2072
so get into strongman find a group in
baton rouge and then that turns into oh
there's a highland games to go do so i
go do one of those um immediately
how many people are there and for people
that don't know what is highland games
so highland games is uh
the scottish heavy athletics is i guess
what it's called and so what they used
it for was when the english took over
scotland and they weren't allowed to
train for battle anymore what was this
like 1600s or even earlier i don't know
i don't know that much but
nice back when they were doing those
things and taking over scotland like
braveheartish times okay nice we'll use
that as a reference
gibson okay yeah got it um
after the dinosaurs before tesla
uh
and so like so clans would meet up and
have these gatherings and they what kind
of clan what kind of clan are we talking
about so like just different countries
dude in scotland that would be like
family okay got it like mclaren or or
any of the other whatever they're crazy
scottish names okay cool
that's a good clan and so they would
challenge each other and these were a
handful of the athletic events they also
did like track and field events they did
um all those type of things so it's like
scottish breakdance battles
[Laughter]
[ __ ] love you that's the best way to
do it that's what breakdancing was right
it's for people that grew up in the hood
how can we battle without violence i'll
do this and i'll do this and i'll spin
on my back and that means i shot your
mom but then you come back and spit on
your head and you shot my dad oh no i'm
so sad it's like the whole beat it video
it's a very confusing video why don't
they just dab each other's hands if
they're if you have a knife
but this is more like my family is
stronger than yours
i get it i get it back in the day and so
because they couldn't train for battle
they would use farm equipment
and essentially still train so you had
hammers that they would throw they'd use
stones they throw they'd have the
weights they throw and the weights came
from like
uh the counterbalances that you would
use on scales for
weighing out grain that you were going
to sell
and so
got into that sport and uh got good at
it pretty quick with the throwing
background and then being relatively
strong competed in it for about
10 years
uh
won two world championships okay who's
the one that won the there's like what's
the most that anyone's ever wanted this
from what i saw it was only six i think
it's six dan mckim may be the guy and
the reason why i bring that up because i
i watched a lot
but you're still like that like that's
it though like you've won two of those
yeah i want two that's amazing and i
don't know the percent i was the only
guy to beat him out of out of his six
that's why i brought that up i wanted
you to flex i i our point here is to
because we our friends are super humble
and they've achieved so much and you're
just not flexing type of people so what
we want to do is we want to flex all
right for our friends so that's why i
brought that up specifically are you
considered the michael jordan of
highland games i'm not
i don't i don't know currently like if
if you're on a wikipedia page bro do i
you are you're on are you the scottie
pippen of the highlander i go with that
more of a mugsy bugs really what a stud
i love that okay um but yeah it was fun
and so like yeah i had two days where
i was able to get the best of him but
man he was such a hard competitor to
beat going in with a throwing background
already
did you feel like you're going into a
sport where you're like wait i know how
to throw things the right way or right
way and these guys are throwing things
the more
leveragy yeah like the more uh
traditional way and it might not be so
scientific did you go like i have an
edge on these guys you absolutely do
yeah you have an edge on it because you
already know how to accelerate
implements and apply force and the
technique of what makes that work from
throwing with the college background
right it's like having a 10-year head
start
and all that works really well until
you're in the pro class and then
everyone knows how to throw because
everyone has the same background
everyone in the pro class are all washed
up ex throwers
and
it's an interesting sport because really
good throwers
go to the olympics
they don't go to this that makes sense
makes sense right and so i get it
everyone in the highland games is like a
second tier
thrower and so it was so much fun of a
sport like we got paid there was prize
money i got travel around the world it's
ridiculous yeah um by far the coolest
thing i've ever got to do that that
totally changed everything for me sick
okay so you do that you win two times um
what makes you stop um i uh ended up
injury injury is what finally got me out
it wasn't like a catastrophic failure i
had a knee
start going south on me um i finished my
2016 season i tore a meniscus in
may that's your first first first injury
real injury yeah well i don't have an
acl
at this point like i just i tore it in
college i got it fixed and then i toured
again at a skate park
uh whenever i had the bicycle shop yeah
so it's not your first injury no
no just this is i finally have something
that has to be addressed i see and so
the meniscus gets a tear i fix that and
then finish out that season with the
intention of like it will ride out the
2016 season and then have acl surgery
i'll take off 2017 and 2018 be back at
it
and uh didn't work out like that
um so finished 2016
and had an acl surgery and then had
four more acl surgeries and then a in a
span of what how long uh
three years was the total course of the
surgeries and i had and i had a year in
there that no surgeries happened was it
like because it was botched up and you
have to go back and redo them or it
wasn't just healing um it wasn't healing
and so we were doing cadaver tissue i
since i had the acl that i tore in
college i had already fixed it once
using a patella tendon and so you're
only going to it's all for me all from
you yeah so use your own okay ideally
it's best like it's gonna hold it's
going to take in and so doing the
patella tendon first your only other
option is a hamstring graft well they
that was my original hope for the
surgery in college with the hamstring
and then it didn't work um not like it
failed but they pulled it and there just
wasn't any hamstring tendon like i have
a big hole like in the back of my leg
where they remove it i want to see that
compromise your hamstrings i'm sure it's
not great like i can't quite get my foot
to my butt um but i don't know now if
that's because of the knee or because i
don't have a thing that pulls further oh
my god okay so we'll get there yeah okay
so at this point you are like okay i'm
kind of hanging it up for the highland
games moving on into another space well
that didn't come until way later like
until after the chronic pain stuff
really hammered in and then like i
couldn't walk or do anything anymore
like i very much realized that like oh
we're not rehabbing anymore
like i'll never compete again oh [ __ ]
what did that feel like it was really
weird it was really weird because man i
had gotten lucky enough as an athlete to
find this hobby and find this thing that
i loved and not only that like all my
weird attributes and skills worked for
it i got to be best in the world did a
thing two times
i'm not gonna find a second thing like
people don't have a second thing they
just move over mr michael jordan and now
they [ __ ] kill it in baseball and you
know
kill it in baseball
[Laughter]
[Music]
but i know publicity when i see it yeah
for sure um
yeah so like
once realizing i wasn't gonna compete
like it was a really strange thing and
then
i realized that like it wasn't that i
just couldn't compete like i wasn't
athletic anymore um that was your body
was given out couldn't go up and down
stairs like this right leg was just
trashed
and uh that was a really hard thing
exactly just because you're so capable
you get a scholarship because you're so
[ __ ] capable
uh you're like you said you won a world
championship not once but twice
yeah i can well your identity changes
too right it's almost like as if uh
mariah carey lost her vocal cords
yeah right it's like i'm not a singer
what am i right
so so is this at the point when we meet
you because when we met you you were
working uh you were doing sales for like
a construction company right yeah i
would have met you guys early nine to
five guy yeah i was dabbling in other
things but i was competing i was working
uh in the petrochemical industry so oil
and gas doing outside sales selling i
think refractory service was my last gig
which what is that what the hell is that
uh so like big giant you know what a
kiln is yeah so kilns have like a
concrete inside of them with a kiln it's
like an oven that you would put ceramics
in you never made pots in like
elementary school and you get to put a
coil elementary and that sounds
dangerous kids in fire no no what you do
is in elementary you get clay right you
make a cool little vase or whatever no i
didn't you cover it in this like uh
paint and then when you put it in the
kiln you know it's going to come out
shiny yeah i'm la usd dude
no budget for that [ __ ] ghetto kid right
here so
the bricks that would go in a kiln like
his insulation or like chimney bricks or
any of that that's refractory brick so
they just don't absorb heat well so they
dissipate it so that the other stuff
next to it doesn't melt
um so when you have big incinerators
that are say
a 40 by 50
we have to spray on refractory on the
inside of them so that is refractory we
would install it and people don't know
they need it so you got to go out they
know they need it they just need to
repair oh so it just wears out over time
from cycling different temperatures
expansion contraction what not um so did
that
um yeah when i met you guys would have
been at the arnold the first time yep
like that must have been 2000
all right eleven so now at this point
2011 really maybe yeah it's been a
minute we knew him
we've known him a minute i know i've
known matt for a long time but i know
it's that long so at that point is hate
your brand hey brandon you're wearing it
all now this is the easiest [ __ ] ever um
i appreciate it is this
i speak the truth man um is this now a
thought in your head and you're like i'm
gonna pursue this or are you still kind
of like on the fence um so by that point
i had written the first book and the
book was about training for the highland
games
just stick with what you know right i
talked about the hate in there and then
hate became an apparel brand in october
of 2014
is when it started and uh we've been
doing that since i got fired from the
real job like in 2017
and just never decided to go back
um so when you got fired were you like
cool i'm gonna lean in because that's
scary [ __ ] super scary at this point are
you married or not yet i am married yes
i'm married at that point um
and i kind of know the writings on the
wall with job but like i was thinking
about talking to my dad about it like
i'd wanted to quit because hate's doing
well enough but also
me quitting because you're doing it
simultaneously yeah and
i'm traveling to compete
wow and i'm traveling for outside sales
so i'm all over
but
me losing that job still reduces my
income by 50 percent yeah and that's a
[ __ ] big deal though opportunity yeah
that's a ton of extra how uh why did you
get fired um
i would say i probably wasn't performing
great uh probably because your heart was
already somewhere else 100 sure and like
i can say some stuff about like i don't
believe they were supporting the area
that they had hired me for i'd had some
other things to deal with but the end of
the day it just wasn't a fit anymore
yeah right like whatever yeah um
and super scary
but then yeah just just leaned in
yeah and i think that's the point that i
really uh admire about you when like we
met you you were literally doing all of
that you were traveling you were
networking like you said you were at the
arnold you were sponsoring and talking
to different athletes um and and you
were trying to balance all of it out and
i can see that you really wanted out of
it because like you said hate was doing
well
um and that right there is the moment
that a lot of people get freaked the
[ __ ] out because they're like the
security and the stability like you said
you were making a good income you had
the flexibility you were yeah i was
making almost 200 grand you had a
company vehicle like it was really good
um but like
where were you like [ __ ] it like what
was that moment if you have that
so
by that point too so this is 2017 so i'm
three years into hate like hate's
working
it's not a mystery at that point by that
point like we're already decent sales
and i'm i'm paying my decent sales if
you don't um
2017 was our first year to do like a
million gross
gross revenue so yeah it's amazing yeah
and three years yeah that's crazy yeah
so it got there quick and then it's been
a fight what was the first year like um
so year one
would have been
october so just october to january okay
we did like fourteen thousand fourteen
thousand okay yeah which is still crazy
yeah i'm selling things i'm making i
don't give a [ __ ] this is the coolest
thing ever yeah seriously and it's not
like you were where we were where we had
the back end we already had a fan base
with you uh youtube jk films so that
crossover for us wasn't as scary right
because we had the platform but you were
building that yeah like because that's
[ __ ] rad well i'd done the book and i
had an audience and i had a bit of
following into enough people were asking
me for apparel and i was like [ __ ] i
don't want to do that
because i don't have time because i also
know like hell i can't pack boxes i'm
not gonna have time to do any of that
and then the customer service falls
apart this doesn't work yeah
and uh luckily like my partner uh with
it phil who who runs my warehouse in
topeka he was like
well i could print them and ship them
and handle everything on the back side
i'm like that changes everything yeah
and so we were able to run it that way
immediately like i've always had it
outsourced and i've never looked back
that's so sick so what happened uh what
did you gross the second year
from 14 grand
which is in a few months yeah so 14
grand basically we'll call it the fourth
quarter of the year
was 15 grand the next year we did
112k damn
yeah for the year and that's still
simultaneously having uh yes i have a
real job and i'm competing holy but you
must have been stoked though you're like
my
hobby is making with some real crazy
yeah yeah yeah i remember at that point
like when it was i remember that because
you know i'm running it poorly by that
point right like i'm still just
operating out of that account like it's
my money and doing whatever because it's
it's a it's not a real business yet yeah
um
and so like i remember at that point
being like yo this is more money that
can be spent
it's like this is great
awesome uh
and it isn't by any stretch right and so
yeah it was really cool seeing that and
then year three we had a bigger pop and
so that was into 2016 we did like 7.50
wow so from like 100 up to 750 and then
it's amazing and then 2017 was our first
year over a mill god damn do you
celebrate in any way internally or
externally or with family or anyone like
just because i like i think for most
people
i don't myself included
whether you're working a full-time job
or even getting into business at first
like for the first time i don't think
crossing the seven figure mark is in
your carts no it's really hard like when
i'm in college if someone was was like
do you think you ever make a million
dollars in a year like we're gross like
no that's that's for that's for bill
gates or some [ __ ] you know i'm like
that's right that's not me like i was
trying to be a doctor and i know that's
a high paying job and i thought i would
probably cap out at 200 or at most yeah
right so
dude being able to find a million
dollars is insane yeah like whether
you're a company or an individual i
don't give a [ __ ] like what an
incredible amount that you've been able
to have gravity to have a track to you
yeah uh
and it was it was really cool man like
the business started growing it was just
me and a business partner mike at that
time but he's a couple kids and
all that type of stuff and so as it
became my real job
like i got more serious about it and um
and making a million you were like you
want to fire me i don't really care
right right yeah right and i mean
yeah but i mean we both know that
doesn't translate to my income it's
really you know what it means
yeah
um okay so at this point
great [ __ ] traction with hate you're
like okay this is a [ __ ] i'm i'm
leaning in a hundred percent direction
this job just let me go couldn't be even
better yes it might be a little bit
shaky um you said you were still
competing yeah uh what how many
surgeries do you have at this point
so by this point like like none oh okay
cool none like so i've i win 2012
uh world championship so i'd already won
both world championships before i
started selling a shirt
now i finished
second at any other world championship i
went to
up till 2016 when i retired um
and so i'm still competing and traveling
and like i'm competing a lot
like a lot so i compete like 22 23 times
a year oh wow so for that 10 years
you're never not competing is it math
like every other week uh so your season
would be like first game of the year was
typically in north carolina in
april
and then like last game of the season is
the last weekend of september
wow so i'm putting in 23 games in a six
month
holy [ __ ] and now you can steal some of
that by going to scotland like so i'd go
to scotland and be part of games week
and so i would compete in scotland
like maybe 11 times in 15 days oh [ __ ]
and so it's just a different sport like
it doesn't beat your cns up the same way
like powerlifting does because i'm not
doing any max effort stuff yeah you're
just throwing throwing and so you also
get good at competing especially over in
scotland with that type of deal we're
like i'll throw far enough to win
like i if i don't have to give you 100
today to get the paycheck and win
i'll throw 90. yeah because you got
another 11 games you got to worry about
be smart and like you just treat them
like training
and so you get really good at competing
which has been great because you know
what that translates to the rest of life
is like man i can perform when it counts
that's awesome it's a cool confidence
thing to walk away from from that sport
um
yeah so we've continued there finished
competing and then have just leaned into
the business stuff it's been
an ongoing problem-solving journey of
trying to figure [ __ ] life out yeah
thank you to mack weldon for sponsoring
this podcast all right you guys we are
in the thick of it it is holiday season
it is here
and with it comes the yearly question of
what do i wear to the non-ugly sweater
parties
the adult parties you know the ones i'm
talking about where we have to look dope
men i'm specifically talking to you
because mac weldon is going to make your
life so
easy okay so if you're asking yourself
how do i maximize my time
savoring holiday moments and minimize my
time shopping either for gifts or for
clothes all right so fear not
uh
max weldon is here to the rescue okay
whether it's an office party or just a
party with family and friends or a
holiday party of you
your couch and a game on tv mac weldon
has all the essentials to keep you
stylish and don't forget the most
important thing ladies and gentlemen
comfortable throughout the season and
their innovative daily wear system has
taken the hard work out of outfit
planning with pieces designed to work
together for any occasion saving you
time and sparing you
extra holiday stress okay so we're
talking about top-notch tops
best-selling bottoms and underwear and
accessories that will please even the
scrooges guys on your list
um or at your party okay so again
mac weldon your holiday heavy lifting
will be complete within minutes for
everyone listening right now you're
going to receive 20 off your first order
visit macweldon.com
bail and enter code
b-e-a-w bell that's
macweldon.com bear
that's mac m-a-c-k weldon
w-e-l-d-o-n dot-com slash bail b-e-a-w
and claim you're 20 off okay
let's do it
okay kind of going back um so
hey bran uh you said you retired in 2016
and then the retiring came about because
of yeah because of the knee okay so then
at that point because i remember you
documenting like you've had you said
nine surgeries yeah um and i remember
you documenting one of the last ones
and you're trying to walk and you're
just [ __ ] devastated because it's
like it's been like a failure after a
failure after a failure
um
at what point are you like you know what
and what happened that you're like you
know what [ __ ] this [ __ ] like i'm not
gonna listen to
essentially not listen to what doctors
are telling me in terms of like they
were telling you you're not going to be
able to train again walk again yeah but
like that stuff's so standard and now
that i've had enough surgeries i almost
think of it as just like it's almost
from their standpoint i think we're just
such a litigious society that is a
surgeon as a doctor it's just easier to
be like you're not going to be able to
squat again and then they just remove
all expectations of that so if you ever
get to 135 again you're like prove them
wrong like
it's just easier than to say you won't
yeah i think just legally yeah instead
of disappointing people yeah
oh but a lot of people take that to
heart
and they stop
yeah yeah yeah i i sure i i don't know
but there's also never not enough of i
think cross training and studies
where like you know there's medicine and
then there's sports and i think we
finally are coming across more sports
medicine and actually doctors who lift
whoever rehabilitated and then now i
think in these elite sports circles
still have
the physician
the pt
the person that works on mobility and
they can all kind of come to a
conclusion together and give you a very
well informed conclusion whereas before
the doctor is literally he's like one
slice of the pie but he has to draw
conclusions for the whole thing right
outdated you're never gonna walk you're
never gonna squat again or something
like that and if he's doing total knee
replacement on
someone who's gen pop and not an athlete
an athlete yeah like
yeah i don't need you to give me pt like
i don't need you to count my reps and
sets like i'm not driving here for
physical therapy no matter how important
you're telling me it is because
this is an elective surgery i wanted to
have surgery so my knee gets better why
wouldn't i do the work on the back side
of it that seems really stupid to me
yeah and so i did and it just kept going
bad uh
i would go in after three months of
rehab and get it checked and like oh the
acl graph isn't there anymore oh so it's
like straight back in like i remember
waking not sticking or something it's
just my body would just eat it oh well
so it was just cadaver tissue and so my
body would just dissolve it dissolve it
what the [ __ ] yeah and so like i
remember waking up from sorry i had an
acl surgery and then i had i had this
piece of floating something or other
next to my knee it's crazy what you get
used to
and like if you haven't tolerated my
knee would get weird and i could find
this floating piece and i could push it
out of the way and then my knee wouldn't
hurt anymore
it was like driving an old vehicle
like you're like
you pump the gas twice before you try to
start it don't you yeah there we go
there we go blowing in the cartridge of
my knee essentially is like an old
nintendo
and
so i go in and get that thing pulled out
and like as i'm waking up from surgery
ashley my uh my wife at the time tells
me she's like so the acl is not there oh
[ __ ]
and like oh man i just broke
because that was like number three
okay so it was like [ __ ] another eight
so i'm back in 10 days after that
surgery oh my god
getting good at going in for surgery is
a really weird thing yes what's the
surgery process like because you got to
go through energy oh it's like going in
like like how did how it all plays out
that day and it's just yeah like how
does it play out cause i'm for me i've
witnessed people go through surgeries
and from my understanding
it's a chunk of your life that you just
have to hit pause on
for it could be i don't know a couple
days to like a whole week and i think it
depends on what your life is right like
like that's part of the deal with kind
of our things right like you can't just
stop yeah like i can't take a break from
hate for eight weeks yeah that ain't how
this works yeah and so
i managed to keep all that together
during during that that thing you know
control what you can right yeah i can't
let that fall too yeah because then what
yeah and so
you know fighting not only that the the
fear of you know why would anyone give a
[ __ ] what i'm doing
as a non-athlete i'm not competing
anymore why would [ __ ] anyone care
what again that's your identity right
yeah and so like
you know the longer i've gotten away
from the identity part of it the more i
realize now like what
having this
physical body that i was you know gifted
essentially uh
like what a change that that built
for me growing up like where my
confidence came from like where my
ability came from all those things that
i count on came from the physical side
yeah and i think about people that don't
have that and like how fortunate i was
even though this is crumbled a bit or
whatever
um
that i have this machine to operate in
did you ever did it ever cross your mind
that it might just be easier just to cut
it off
dude that was nine stories
it's a really shitty thing to say but i
had gotten to a point where i was really
desperate with surgeries and really
depressed after how many was that at
that point eight oh [ __ ] yeah after
after eight and like i just don't have
answers man yeah like eight that's fair
not only that like my last two
are
the high tibial osteotomy and this oats
procedure and like both of those were
eight weeks
no toe touch pressure
so just imagine operate your life but
you can't ever put one of your legs on
the ground
wow so you're on crutches
so how do you get food from your
microwave to anywhere how do you cook
how do you get
your glass of water take a shower across
the room
you know like when you have when you're
in such a um
like uh i guess
a vulnerable handicapped state
where you're almost
worse than you were when you were a baby
right
you're kind of a burden now too others
you're burdened to others and yourself
yourself
did it ever cross your mind to go like
[ __ ] why did i ever do this like why did
do you ever regret the success like does
the success now come back to haunt you
at all that never that never popped up
like because at the end of the day
you know i got to travel around the
world with some of my favorite people
ever i don't know you guys without it i
don't know my best friends without it i
don't have the business i don't have
any other things that are going well
like [ __ ] i'll give a leg tomorrow for
it
i made the right move it was well worth
a like i know people with shitty knees
who didn't do anything that's very true
so like that's very
dope perspective
the sport was gonna end
right like that no one gets to do it
forever and so
my time and also in hindsight is i
wasn't going to leave healthy
like that's not how that story was going
to play out and you knew this
about me
and so here we are but had that not
happened
i perhaps i'm still competing which
means my business isn't doing as well i
have a ton of stuff that isn't where it
is right now opportunity wise because i
would have still stayed competing and
you would probably
try to find another another job to
supplement your lifestyle oh going back
you asked you asked about surgery i do
want to i do want to tell about that
like so going in and getting good at it
yeah so i'm driving to new orleans from
baton rouge so it's an hour commute to
the hospital or surgery yeah to the
hospital um i get there usually like
four so by this point i'm damn sure
first in line for the day and you
probably fasted for 12 hours right
because they don't like you eating of
course surgery yeah that was never
something i thought you're back dude
that's huge for me i need to eat really
yeah i need to eat that's funny i love
eating uh so
yeah i'd go in at four and then like
check in and then usually by six they've
got me to a room jesus and then like
i bet i don't get pulled out of the room
to get pulled back for surgery until
11 00 or noon
um so you just sit there in your
hospital room with some lady who comes
in to shave your leg
uh i'm a crappy hospital gown
in bed no underwear no completely open
ass hanging out what i did figure out
was
by surgery three
so when they masturbate one last time
just knock out a couple knuckle children
and move on with my
life children i love it
so i realized like once they take me
back and they're talking to me and
they're like how are things and all this
you know how do you feel are you nervous
or anything like that and they typically
will hit me with uh versed which is
valium so it's injectable valium
it's awesome
yeah it just kills you the [ __ ] nothing
matters everything's great and it's
because at this point your whole body's
achy right yes i'm dealing with a bunch
of [ __ ] it's standard like i'm going in
for surgery by this point i'm just like
i just want this to work
like now it's all i can think about too
is like
with three months of rehab i know what
tomorrow looks like tomorrow is i'm in a
straight leg brace and i'm on the
assault bike using just my arms
to keep blood moving to keep healing
going and all those type of things and
so
what i got good at was as soon as they
got me to my room and they're like how
are you and i'm like i'm anxious
so they would hit me with versailles and
so i'm like sick at four hours with
first set before you guys pull me back
nice like i'm looking forward to it like
i'd put a playlist together on my phone
and bring your headphones and be like
yeah make uh make lemons make lemonade
wherever you can i suppose and then yeah
get out of surgery go home uh it's
really weird i tried i did i did a
epidural one time you can't drive home
right no no so ashley would typically
drive me home someone needs to drive you
and then someone picks you back up yeah
so she would hang out
i know that's wrong all of that crushes
me yeah it sucks when you have to hate
being a burden yeah me too i hate it
when i like when i got my eye surgery
did you drive me home that day or i
drove myself no i drove you okay i
picked you up because all my other
checkups and appointments where they
have to do stuff like they they use this
laser to blast holes in your iris i
still just drove home so i don't want to
be a burden to her dude i hate it so i
would put on these special uh like
sunglasses and because they just blasted
holes through my iris
everything would be hazy and i'm like
like this can't be worse than my grandpa
driving so i'm just like oh my god
i'm just figuring it out i'll just stay
in there slowly
with that feeling of like being a burden
right being a burden yeah
do
so there's part of me that doesn't want
to be a burden
but then there's also the other side of
me that's aware the reason i feel this
way is i
i don't want to be involved in your [ __ ]
either
and so like if i don't ask you for help
you're not allowed to [ __ ] ask me for
help yeah
interesting right so there's part of it
like yeah i don't want to go pick you up
[ __ ] uber yeah yeah and it's just
like i will not call my friends to help
me move yeah i'm not that guy for you
yeah yeah i get it i don't want to help
my threshold is different though for me
unless i'm abs like because the day of
my eye surgery
i just you know i'm like i'm put under
like there's so many things i just can't
legally even drive so of course i need
her anything above that line i'm driving
but for her if she has anything like
that i don't mind
totally different yes totally different
and i don't mean that for like my
partner i mean that for like friends
yeah yeah yeah it'd be like one of my
buddies noted matt we're not going to
ask you for [ __ ] help dude hey man
we're moving
and like i'll help but i'm coming to
move the five really heavy things that
you need moved yeah yeah i ain't loading
your bag of pillows into the [ __ ] if my
friends ask me to move
i'm paying for a moving company so we
can both like chill out drink beers and
watch them do it yeah
noted
you know yeah free movers just call bart
just call me i'll call the movie yeah
okay so then at this point um
i want to get into the mindset of all of
this right because obviously you're
getting [ __ ] wrecked you're getting
crushed you're thinking you're the
burden like just you talking about it
now and we're living that you feel like
you just feel heavy again yeah
what did that feel like and how did you
overcome that
just
overcoming feeling like a burden
um like losing your identity yeah how
did all that like what did you go
through like let's go into the the
depths if you don't mind of that
darkness and then finding ways to get
yourself out of that yeah like um so
losing your identity thing is huge
then trying to repair your identity but
having eight failures yeah i think is it
goes down even more
and then also you must have been in a
state of depression where you must have
been like i don't know where to go from
here for sure so so there's there's that
there's those three factors and then
there's the real factor of chronic pain
that i'm dealing with too
and the chronic pain thing man like to
describe it like where i
while i've never felt with any like
depression in my life but prior to this
and it wasn't really until after that
i'm able to realize what i'm doing what
i have going on i get you um
but man the chronic pain thing it's like
my pain level was always between a two
and an eight
so it's never less than that not if i'm
laying still
flat
it's never not a two would you consider
a what do you consider a toothache what
level of pain is that so i can kind of
understand
uh i mean it depends on how bad the
toothache is but
i don't know one
a one yeah like when you stub your toe
in the middle a man on a couch what is
that
but that's such an acute pain right like
so acute pain is a really different
thing versus chronic the chronic pain
thing is it's a tube but it never
[ __ ] goes away it's essentially like
trying to manage your day
and tycho 100 tugging at you saying hey
hey hey hey oh my god but even if you
stop to address him he just doesn't stop
yeah oh [ __ ] and so like you can go and
hang out with friends but there's still
the hey hey hey and it can be loud
enough you don't notice it
but as soon as you're by yourself
you're there and it must affect your
sleep too dude sleep's bad i'm also
sleeping a bunch of nights in a straight
leg brace like
and
then throw in you know a you know
marriage
and so
during that stretch of time too we were
we were trying to have a kid so 18
months of trying to have a kid while i'm
trying to do surgeries while
it's just running a new business
it's just too much
you know and uh the marriage lost it was
a real bummer um
but
we had we had to go forward you know
yeah and uh and was that due to all of
these things happening or is it because
you guys just changed as people both oh
[ __ ] both and i think this was a big
part of that change for me uh was
it it all started really the big change
for me started whenever my my dad had
passed away in uh 2014. so that happens
in april so my dad dies the day before
my birthday oh god dude in april uh
so he dies at 62 from pancreatic cancer
i turn 31 the next day
and all i can think about is like
halfway
you're [ __ ] halfway there half of
your life's gone and so like man that
translates to me that that translates to
1612 weeks
that's it that's all of it
you know and maybe the cards are stacked
in my favor to be a little bit older
than 62 when i go but that ain't
guaranteed i'll live accordingly
and so so that moment right there that
shifted a bunch that shifted a bunch of
like if that's true and i do have this
amount of time left that means all my
dreams everything i want to experience
everything i can ever think of has to
happen in the next 1612 weeks god damn
or it doesn't
that's it
and so get busy
so try to shift into that and then you
know that's 2014 so then i start the
apparel company and things are building
momentum and then there's this
and so it's fight
i still feel the same way about my life
and then trying to figure it out and so
at this point dude i am doing everything
i can figure out to mitigate the chronic
pain so i've switched my diet i'm down
60 pounds i've done carnivore for eight
months because it's anti-inflammatory
i've done keto for a really long time
i'm i'm trying peptides i'm growth
hormone uh you know if it's a
possibility to help yeah i'm in yeah two
to eight uh chronic pain i get it and so
when it was bad and what would cause it
to go bad was like oh maybe i walked too
far that day like 200 yards total wow
not like it once yeah
and like i mean i can't step up stairs i
can't
and uh
when it was really bad and really
inflamed like i would get a shooting
pain that i would say is like a nine out
of ten because it could be worse i could
be on fire
right so it's not a 10. yeah i don't
know that 10 exists and i don't know if
zero exists but so that's where i am i'd
get this like stabbing pain on the
medial side of my knee
uh every time i exhale oh no when it
hits are you like stumbling to look for
pills are you like you're like i gotta
take something like make this like i
switched to cannabis
like so i i just
helped dude it helped me a ton so
opiates
work they make the pain go away but i
can't do anything else oh you're [ __ ]
just part of the couch yeah and i mean
look time in a place like if i if pain
for me gets to an eight or a nine
that that's what we're doing
but
if it's a two i don't need a percocet i
need another option and so cannabis
helped me a ton with that that
that was a really big game changer for
me of figuring out how to mitigate with
that um you don't feel the pain anymore
and you're able to function yes oh
that's cool yeah so to an extent
you know um
it it and it definitely kept me
happier i know i'm more depressed the
more that i take viking opiates
uh so pot didn't make me that way it
just got fatter
the munchies the munchies hit real good
yeah one thing at a time so like uh were
you still training when you were going
through all this pain and stuff like
were you just hitting upper body or
anything like that much as you can and
is that just a
part of the habit or the discipline that
you had or is it you're just a meat head
or
you control what you can control right
like when things are chaotic like i
can't let the [ __ ] that i'm that's
working slip too
yeah because
then what yeah that's another mindset to
have because there's like a lot of nba
players
the minute they're injured they gain 30
pounds yeah i'm not doing [ __ ] well and
i gained weight you're just not doing as
much but man i did everything i could to
stay active like spend a lot of time on
the assault bike with a leg and a
straight leg brace just sitting on the
front peg and just using them because
you can arm yeah it's it's the greatest
recovery tool that's ever been made is
that is that awful bike
it is awful but it's so awesome
man and yeah so the mindset shift so
like i you know got hooked up with some
other friends that were leaning into
psychedelics and i went that route and
found a ton of benefit and this is
through 2014 this is 2014 or is it
throughout the years so this has started
psychedelics probably started in
2017 2018. okay so kind of moving back a
little bit we're still 2014. uh
you're on what surgery number at that
point
by 2018 yeah uh no 14. 2014 so because
this is right where you were in 2014
there's no surgeries yet first first
surgery starts in 2016. so dad dies okay
um got it got it yeah so we've continued
on got it okay
so then you're dealing with that um now
possibly having a kid
trying for 18 months and not
successfully doing it and then man and
so at this point is though is the
relationship already kind of rotted
because oh [ __ ] it's rough and like
man i i i [ __ ] overlooked some big
stuff in that relationship and i and i
see it now and especially on the back
end and i've you know had a fortunate
enough time that i still have a
relationship with ashley that i can
express yo i [ __ ] up i'm super sorry
that's awesome do you mind sharing yeah
some of those things were
so
when i went down to costa rica for
ayahuasca uh the first time
really expecting
this big transformative thing like i've
never had more
expectation of a big experience coming
people where were you going there in
search of that
just just a transformation just i just
want to know like i've seen nothing but
good stuff happen to smart people i know
for for trying this so you're doing that
just for the sake of that not because
there's a void or perspective change
you're searching for in your own
personal life well and like i i want to
be better so i want to be more aware of
my [ __ ] i don't know yeah where did you
feel like you were lacking though like
where did you feel that there was like a
short is it because of
this relationship that ended that you're
like oh [ __ ] i don't know got more [ __ ]
um and so i'd started with psychedelics
before that just because i wanted the
mindset shift i'd also become friends
with some friend some people who were
using more and were smart
and so seeing that operate like in the
real world was really fascinating and i
was like okay i'm interested so for
example for me right i guess this is
what this is what at least i'm trying to
find so for me when i wanted to um have
my mind shift i haven't done ayahuasca
and i definitely want to try it um
but for me it was like i just want
deeper connections with people
so that was like my driving force for
you it's like i just want to untap some
[ __ ] that i don't know about yes oh [ __ ]
it was on tap some stuff i don't know
about and also like
find more drive find more intention five
find more way to sort out
my
80d or
you know lean into it i get it because
your dad passed now you have like this
finite amount of time
got it so you're like i need to speed
this [ __ ] up hit the super yeah i needed
to ferris this [ __ ] yeah it's exactly
right and so um
during that like so i get two nights
where nothing happens
how many nights do you get to take four
okay so four nights that were there the
first two nights i get nothing the whole
experience too like you're there's a
bucket where you need to throw up into
right yeah so you purge
not everyone that doesn't sound very fun
you know
it's it's not right like that and i
understand that apprehension that people
have but man is it immediate like you
drink the tea and you're like like
really you go lay down and some people
get nauseous and some don't did you get
nauseous i did uh the third night yeah i
finally purged
why do they call it a purge because
that's what it feels like like like
because you're in it and in the medicine
yeah like dude you feel like you are
getting rid of your garbage i think i've
felt that before so when we were going
through our relationship [ __ ] it was so
awful that we were like okay we need to
connect on some other level and
how can we do this so at this point he
has done in high school he did so much
[ __ ] ecstasy
that he was like well this is the only
time i know how to connect with people
heart to heart completely vulnerable i
know how to like have these deeper
relationships and connections through
that vehicle so we're like and it's a
good one
we i had no idea okay so at this point
i'm [ __ ] desperate and i'm like all
right let's do whatever
so we both take it um are you all
married at this point or not yes very
married very married barbell's
established jk is established we're like
what six years into our relationship
okay um
and yeah we were just talking through
you know everything that we had gone
through things that we didn't even know
we were sweeping under the rug or uncut
or like covering up or
like we started really like fighting for
the other person in our own mind and as
that was happening and things were
getting uncovered it like i just wanted
to throw it all up and i felt like i was
throwing up all the bad [ __ ]
so i can completely relate with what
you're saying i mean
and plenty of places are now using mdma
therapy
with couples like it's
md i you know forgive me for getting
stuff wrong here but uh i mean exit your
mdma is treated like a i guess it's not
one of the classic psychedelics so lsd
acid mushrooms you're not
no but there is something there is an
altered state and there is a heart
opening that comes with it yeah there's
an extreme rush of empathy and i think
that really helped us out because when
we were going through our dark times in
our relationship
like they're the bad guy
and once that person and your
significant other becomes a bad guy in
their mind every other thing that
happens in life instead of being on
their side you're like questioning why
you're doing that like that okay that's
what happens when resentment shows up
exactly and resentment's really hard to
undo yeah and but with that when we're
doing our ecstasy stuff there's an
extreme amount of empathy to the point
where you can almost get that person's
back in your own mind and then now i'm
producing the answers i'm like you know
when you did this it wasn't because of
this huh it was because of this i was
like yes
yeah it was awesome finally it was
really awesome yeah i mean and that's it
was something that triggered a ton for
me with uh with aya like so the the
third night like one of the things i i
i envision
um
and i mean it's it's it i didn't get any
like big visuals like i had taken
mushrooms i got it was all internal
and so uh one of the things is yeah like
i see myself laying on a bed on the bed
at my house
uh back in louisiana and my knees done
up post surgery
and i'm miserable and i'm laying there
and i'm bummed and i remember just
thinking like why don't you [ __ ] work
like like all the people out there that
that they're gonna have good knees and
don't [ __ ] need them like mine like
mine i'll use mine and i have all that
bitterness and that anger about it right
and i'm looking at it and i'm being mad
that my [ __ ] body doesn't work it
doesn't do the thing it's supposed to do
and like as i i turned or something
happened and i look back at the bed
and it's ashley
and i never during that stretch of time
put together that like her not being
able to get pregnant was the same thing
i have with my leg yeah wow and like man
i just [ __ ] missed it
i just missed it that she also feels
broken yeah
and like [ __ ] that was rough
and you're so focused on your own thing
that your your blinders are just buried
so you don't even know what she was
going no
just buried and uh
it was a good realization so yeah the
empathy thing is hey i needed it because
it's not a strong suit that i came
naturally equipped with yeah uh
but man that's been a huge one and not
only just huge empathy for the people in
my life but you know having empathy for
me
has been has been really uninteresting
what's that like give us that okay
what's that
yeah that was [ __ ] hard like that
that period of life is really really
hard i don't want to underplay it i
don't want to pretend that it wasn't
hard i don't want to pretend that it
wasn't
rough or hard on her or hard on me or
shaping or any of those things and so
you know being able to forgive myself
for some [ __ ] decisions i made or any of
these other type of things with just
like
dude you weren't okay
yeah but you just were unaware hey no
you just can't see it yeah
that you know that the actions you're
taking are completely out of character
because you just don't know what to
[ __ ] do
and so you're just looking for solace
somewhere
and um
yeah was there at any point though where
you were like
[ __ ] i'm just going to throw in the
towel like i just want to end it all
like i don't want to be here i never
ever got suicidal like i don't remember
having any blatant suicidal thoughts one
thing you said earlier about like the
leg i had that discussion with my
surgeon when i went in before total knee
replacement at 30 at like 36 like they
don't want to do total knee replacement
you're 36 you're too young
and i basically was like yo i need
something yeah
but otherwise i got to get rid of the
leg yeah because
i
i can't continue like this
i know i know that
i know that
like i never had suicidal thoughts but i
knew that i couldn't run out the clock
feeling how i felt
that at some point it would have got the
best of me and i'd have punched out
yeah
um
and man
i [ __ ] get it i get it with the
chronic pain because there's just time
with it that like
i i can remember having moments and
sitting there and just being like i
[ __ ] need 10 minutes
where this doesn't hurt
i just need 10 [ __ ] minutes and i can
sort it out and i can catch my breath
and i can be back in it wow and you just
can't find room that's [ __ ] crazy and
so like the only time that the chronic
pain wasn't an issue was either in the
hot tub or in the cold tub god damn
that's it
those are the only time i could get it
quiet and i think just part of that is
since overlapping children probably that
one yeah or we're jerking all the
options how many times can i do that a
day seven eight at most
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah so it was
so like most people could be like all
right well i'm just gonna give up on all
these other things i'm gonna try to
focus on this one thing um maybe i can
get government assistance maybe i can
just kind of like
let all this other [ __ ] go and just
focus on this one thing but you were
still running a whole bunch of other
[ __ ] how distraction
i need it too
damn you know what i mean at least those
things weren't requiring me to
physically do look he got really old
making [ __ ] rehab content
who the [ __ ] wants to see me rehab again
for the ninth time in three years like
ugh
sorry i i personally really loved your
rehab content okay because i think what
i liked about it more from the actual
know-how and application
i can sense your spirit of climbing a
mountain
you know what i mean like when i when i
would watch your content it wasn't like
i mean my knees work perfectly fine
don't be jealous
you [ __ ]
but it wasn't like okay so i can use
that apply it to my life but seeing
someone that has had so much adversity
and i would see you try to box squat
it's inspiring it's cool i can squawk i
could squat 135 slightly above parallel
right now
seeing that was extremely inspiring
seeing someone slowly climb the mountain
back up and just seeing what you do
getting back on the bike pumping blood
through it it was it was awesome i loved
it it was just like this
seeing like what you would see from a
inspirational nike commercial or movie
or whatever but happening in real life
in real time i appreciate it man and and
that was the intent that i wanted to
show that i wanted to show that like yo
i still show up yeah i love it you know
that what are we gonna do stop
what the [ __ ] does that occur i love
that you were vulnerable enough to open
that up and not have ego and i mean
because you're a [ __ ] world champion
dude this is so vulnerable for you to
not
feel capable or strong
and then to show that to the public a
lot of people don't want that's an ugly
side it's an embarrassing side for some
people and it's crazy that it still
rears its head like it's it hasn't been
until the last probably six or eight
weeks
that since 2016 i have not followed a
consistent training program
since then i'll just go to the gym and
do whatever i want yeah because it
doesn't matter i'm not training for
anything
other than when i did the run and then i
just ran yeah and i want to talk about
that too goddamn your story so far
and so like now being back on a
consistent training program like i could
feel my ego about it too because you
know my back's jacked up my hips jacked
up and so like yo i have deadlifts or
something tomorrow or whatever day it is
and like i'm pulling
from blocks
with like 155.
oh [ __ ] and
yo that's not cool to show people
but you're still doing it it's not cool
to show people but at the end of the day
like here's where i am
this is real and i think that's what's
really motivating yeah and so today if i
got it i'll lift heavier if i don't i'll
do the bar that's [ __ ] that's big
dick energy dude
it's it's moving a pile of dirt it's my
favorite way i've heard it described
that life and and like how you're trying
to make progress john wellborn says it
it's a move in a pile of dirt some days
you got a backhoe and other days you got
a spoon
you should keep moving dirt yeah
yeah or what some people say one foot in
front of the other that's it chip away
at it well like and i got that honestly
from you guys like so the first time i
came out and we filmed and talked about
everything
uh years ago
um i mean you guys even saying that like
we don't know how to open a brick and
mortar gym so we bought a book for how
to open brick and mortar for dummies
i started salivating dude just close it
just spit on it it's too familiar
[Applause]
[Music]
but yeah like so like oh [ __ ] what were
we talking about uh that we were going
like we don't know what the [ __ ] we're
doing we gotta [ __ ] and so like even
here and you guys say that it was like
so we'll just take the next step until
we run into one we can't figure out yeah
literally
and it's easy when you start breaking
stuff down that way of like well there's
a next step
so we'll just deal with that one
and i mean yeah i treated rehab with
that approach i treat everything that
way like there's let's just figure out
just move what tomorrow does yep
you know and
you know that that fallacy i think a lot
of people fall into of the like well
we'll get there once we're there yeah
where i do this this will change yep i
know how it works yeah it all changes in
the journey yeah so if you don't like
the journey
getting there ain't gonna do [ __ ] for
you yep what about after the ayahuasca
trip like when you had your
revelation like what were your next
steps or
actions that you felt like you needed to
take and how did that so so that's
integration and that that's a big part
of using the plant medicine and stuff
like that like yo it's not going to
change you like if you take that and
have this big awakening experience and
have a bunch of stuff like it kind of
gives you a fresh start to start
inlaying new habits and patterns
um but if you fall into your [ __ ] it'll
happily let you have it
like you'll you'll just go back to
building your patterns again they just
like that intrinsic reward system for
weird patterns and habits that you have
whether emotional or any of that
just seemed to be clear
and so i could start fresh on a lot of
stuff and it's like yo if i don't want
to approach with that
immediate negative mindset like i knew
for a long time i'm a guy that if a
thing popped up as a stress
it was
panic [ __ ]
freak out
and then i could come around
and that window is continued to get
shorter sick right that like yo this is
a wasted amount of energy we know we're
gonna get here let's just stop the freak
out
and you got that through ayahuasca being
able to implement like what is the freak
out about the freak out is an anxiety
about a thing that has not happened yeah
stop oh what i was asking about is when
you realized
the whole knee thing and you drew the
parallel with what ashley was going
through about the baby like
um when you went home what was that
conversation well so by that point like
uh bonnie and i are together i'm
divorced like i've been divorced for
a year oh so it was the time i did iowa
so it was a revelation that helped like
untie some knots that were like three
yeah just like as soon as i got a chance
to see her in person i was like yo i
have to explain this to you i see that's
awesome yeah and i was like man i am so
[ __ ] sorry i missed that yeah
oh and
when she heard that was she like yeah
that's what i felt
and she and she was like yo thank she's
like thank you because she doesn't have
the words for a lot of it either right
yeah most people don't right you don't
realize what you're too close yeah and
so you have more feelings than you have
words that you know yeah so that that
empathy
went a long way
of like
okay and that and that's helped a ton
just across the board with anyone i deal
with or anything in any stressful
situations being able to
own
yeah how my interaction with the
situation goes completely
and then have empathy for like you know
i don't know what's shaping your
decisions i don't know what your last
six weeks have looked like i don't know
how you were as a kid yeah
and so like i control what i control
and i don't take the rest of it personal
did this come after you started
experimenting with like psycho
psychologists were you always this way
no never this way
it wasn't great
yeah because i see every time i think of
you i just think of you as like
this like
very vulnerable very open honest dude
it's gotten better
um how are you what the [ __ ] how are you
before i mean i i would say i was more
not not standard dude anyway but like
for sure just artist
nerdy creative guy that wants to do
weird [ __ ] but also the jock side
and so like having that side and the
confidence that came with it like i'm
still cocky and still arrogant and
plenty of [ __ ] ego and narcissistic i
mean
the narcissism thing is a really strange
one because i mean i am filming myself
doing rehab in a garage
like there's a weird business the
motivation's different though because
like when you're an athlete you kind of
have to be narcissistic you have to
really envision and believe that you're
the [ __ ] [ __ ] it's what gives you the
competitiveness you know right yeah but
then to share it i didn't see it as
narcissistic i just saw it as you have
something that is helping you and you're
like well who else can it help i'm
putting it out there sure sure but i
mean the narcissism point of like uh
you know whether that was starting a
podcast or doing any of these other
things it was like you know my
conversations are pretty great i should
share those and maybe make money
it's a weird thing like at least i'll
just sit and be aware of like that that
switch is in there and like [ __ ] keep
an eye on it
that's true
but
yeah it it was it was tough man it was
tough figuring those things out and
finding that empathy and like what a
difference that made and not just
empathy but then gratitude
and like gratitude for
maybe not for the injury
but
you know i got 10 years of my athletic
career that i got to just pour gasoline
on this fire
and my body did nothing but [ __ ]
respond
for 10 years let's go get bigger get
stronger get faster throw further win
like you said about your two good knees
he had that
and then i didn't
right and uh yeah man the way
that again it was never gonna be long
term i mean that's a dope perspective
it's never gonna be long term yeah and i
don't know when it was going to end but
it did um
and so
man just just having that gratitude that
like yo i got to travel around the world
for 10 years and do a sport that i love
like i'm born at the right time right
place to get to do that you know not
only that like
i got to travel and do it with my
brother like he competed as a
professional in the highlander who gets
to share that yeah that's rare at that
point too like i'm bummed because the
sport's gone so i also don't have
the 10 guys that i've traveled around
the world with anymore and i see those
dudes every weekend
and the cool part with the highland
games is like there's no highland games
gyms there's no community
it's just us when we see each other on
the weekends everyone trains by
themselves
and so then that's gone and so like
these other lunatics that get it
aren't in my life anymore yeah and it's
not a fault of theirs like we know
that's how it goes i mean what are they
gonna [ __ ] do follow me around and
ask how my knee is all the time like
they have [ __ ] to do they're training
too
and uh
then that shift and so my brother you
know i don't see him every weekend
anymore so there was just a lot of
changes that well lost dude yeah it
feels like loss
even even getting back with my brother
on it and being able to say like
you know our relationships change and
it's in it's a bummer to me
but that's okay like i can't believe i
got to travel with you and share all
that time like family members don't do
that yeah and so having the gratitude
for like what a cool chapter that was
despite that it's over
so let's worry about the next chapter
being is rad too
not focused on that one it's done that's
all red that's the thing i've noticed um
we've had several guests already on this
podcast and they've all they're all
killers in their field you know like
they've dominated whatever it is that
they set out to
accomplish
um and everyone has this championship
this champion mindset of like
the glass is half empty but it's also
half full
um and it's all perspective and i see
that time and time and time again like
that winner mindset of like
yeah okay yeah [ __ ] is [ __ ] up okay
how did i contribute to this [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] up okay what changes can i make
to make it less [ __ ] up yeah
i i see that time and time and time
again and that that's why i'm like so
grateful that you're here being as
vulnerable and sharing this story
because
um we all go through so many [ __ ]
obstacles and life tests us and like
it's really your response to it you know
some people cave in and they're like no
i don't want to and unfortunately they
don't get to live the life that or the
universe that you say that you like you
create your own universe you believe it
man yeah and you're a true example of
someone that's like yeah um yeah i'm not
laying down uh well
i'm gonna be dead at some point like
that's coming i know it yeah but some
people however anyways it's like 1200
weeks at this point is what i have i've
seen your [ __ ] marbles man and every
time you throw a marble away it makes me
a little bit anxious yeah i don't like
it because
because like the other side of that too
i don't much believe in an afterlife uh
and so really not really
damn i can see now why rogan has like
four hour podcasts i feel like i can
keep diving deeper and deeper and deeper
uh and so
like whether i spent that past week like
obligated to do [ __ ] because i'm
supposed to and i'm following the status
quo and i went to these job meetings and
i did this stuff and i'm not fulfilled
but i'm doing
the right thing
right white picket fence the two weeks
vacation the whole whatever that safety
thing is we're convinced of
or
i can spend my life completely chasing
the things i love and figuring it out
and being completely responsible that if
it doesn't work it's my [ __ ] fault
both paths still end with me in the
ground there's not a risk
to trying
right do you see you don't believe in
the afterlife to say that like you're
just [ __ ] gunning it the entire way
here because it's just one shot one life
that's it
[ __ ] that's it i now
if i'm gonna make a stretch on how i'd
feel about the afterlife
i i believe in kind of the idea of the
conservation of energy energy is not
created or destroyed yeah i think this
is a really interesting point in my
energy's
existence that i have a physical form
but this may be the only chapter that i
get a physical form
so after that you're just i don't know
part of the earth and no clue come dirt
or whatever no clue whatsoever damn i
mean do i think it's fluffy clouds in
heaven i don't do i think it's hell i
don't
[ __ ] have you seen his marble thing that
he does so he has a jug of uh oh how
many marbles is it is it sixteen hundred
and twelve yeah so he has a jug of these
marbles that represent every day of his
life until every week
every week of his life and then at the
end of the week he gets one he walks it
over to the trash can and throws it away
so it's like a visualization of like how
much time perceived time he has left and
so like let let's say i make it to 62
right
and i'm healthy you are gonna make it to
62. i'm sure
uh but i'm also aware that if i get in
the car today to drive somewhere in town
like that's not a zero percent success
rate
that's a realistic way i look at it it's
very unlikely but it isn't a zero
and
you know if if my time gets punched
today
you know my time for the last eight
years hasn't been spent not doing the
things i want to do you i look at you
and bonnie's instagram and i just look
at how you guys live life and it's so
[ __ ] beautiful you guys have such a
beautiful relationship um you guys like
compliment each other not like literally
compliment each other but like nice you
look great but like your lifestyles
complement each other you guys
are are very independent people but very
united still um you travel the [ __ ]
world you hang out with friends like you
just saw our friend uh steffy cohen
fight in [ __ ] dubai that was super
fun initially was supposed to be in
florida the last minute changing you're
like yep i'm going there well i was
already in africa so it made sense but
still you know what i mean like the the
the fact that you've curated your life
to support whatever [ __ ] wild
decision that you want is absolutely
fascinating and so [ __ ] inspirational
well i mean but you guys have done the
same like i mean you know to throw the
compliment back bonnie and i both feel
that way about being around you guys
throw it back dude because we're talking
about you
and we're couch livers couch lovers man
we're so we were just talking about this
yesterday because you guys are like you
guys live like you're gonna die tomorrow
which is cool and it's even cooler that
you have this cool visual representation
representation of how much time you have
left so i think you have this weekly
reminder
of how much time you have left where
most people i think they understand that
their time is limited but if you're not
reminded of things you you're gonna live
like you have infinite time infinite
money infinite everything you know and i
just think it's so cool that you
actually for the last i don't know how
long i've known you every single month
it looks like you're living as if that's
conscious on your mind yep
it is i i wish that anxiety would go
away sometimes and like i'd be able to
lay on the couch a little bit better but
it doesn't work so good um
i i like it i like the way that it makes
me feel like i mean how many stories do
you hear about those people that like
you know find out they have some
terminal thing
and then they just step on the gas pedal
of life because there isn't a risk
anymore hmm
like yo you're [ __ ] terminal now yeah
why don't you do that now right i am
right yeah that's that's how i feel
about it like yo i'm terminal damn uh
what advice would you give to someone
and then we'll wrap it up uh because i
feel like we can talk for [ __ ] ever i
[ __ ] love this episode um what advice
would you give to someone that's a
little bit more risk adverse
yeah like someone
and i'm sure you probably get this in
the comments and dms all the time
someone that's
a little bit more risk adverse which i
think
all of us have been there right like
you had a nine of five you had the cushy
job the white picket festive you know
like you had the dream american dream
job
like what advice would you give someone
that is in that state of mind but sees
how you grab life by the horns and want
to go in that direction
like what can they do or what what's a
different perspective that they can have
to accelerate that transformation one i
i think is just complete honesty about
it and one of those things about the
complete honesty about it is understand
that if you'd like to do this thing and
build your own life and create your own
thing which is your own income your own
everything
you're never not at work anymore
just go ahead and [ __ ] deal with that
but i don't look at that as a weird
thing because
success for me and like what i would
like to accomplish
was going to be hard work either way
whether that was supporting someone
else's business and working my ass off
for it to get what i wanted or i can
invest in me
i'd rather take the shot at investing in
me and for that risk adverse person like
man
if you've got it if you've got what it
takes to figure out this hustle and
entrepreneur life
it's not a risk to take a shot at you're
hireable
like if you can kind of make this work
for any stretch of time you're so
valuable to someone else who can figure
it out
they'll [ __ ] hire you yeah
because
people in our spots need so much help
because you have we're just talking
about that right because
i still only have 24 hours
and so the only thing i can do with time
is in time such an interesting commodity
because i can't buy any more of it but i
can buy yours and i can sell mine
and so i have to multiply by buying time
from other people to do the work that i
can't do in a single day so now we can
do three times the work
and man good help's great you have to
have it
and people that buy in and do all that
so like man
if you've got what it takes to figure
your thing out run with it
and
find out
like [ __ ] going into the ground
wondering what if
yeah i'd way rather fail
i'd so much rather fail like the big
failures i've had
uh like bike shop or you know any of
these other type of things like
you used to own a bike shop yep that was
the first first shot at trying to work
for me was uh was opened a bicycle shop
and it finally failed miserably um but
man i learned a lot
open to brick and mortar i understand
what didn't work
and and have applied that going forward
and i think the more that you can kind
of
non-emotionally look at stuff and just
look at like did this work did this not
work
what's the data
make an intelligent decision
and treat that risk that way
instead of
expecting it to go in any way you think
it's going to go yeah and just have the
intention of like let's figure out the
next step yeah
yeah i love that i [ __ ] love it i
love everything you're doing i love
everything you stand for
um i know you personally know you
personally and you're the [ __ ] truth
man and i [ __ ] i love you for it we
love you for it that's why we call you a
brother that's we call you family
so grateful that you gave us this time
i'm happy
to be here
yes but that's the beauty of it right
because i own that
yo i'm never where i don't want to be
i'm not obligated to be here yeah so if
i'm not obligated be present
and that's like i deal with that with my
mom because like family gatherings and
[ __ ] like that i don't want to go to
and so what i have explained to her is
like so i'll never come to a thing i
don't want to come to i'll just tell you
no
but if i'm there
you don't ever have to question it
and so like i'll give you both you get
both sides of that coin is that if i'm
here and i'm with you know that there
isn't anywhere else i want to be and i
don't feel obligated to hang out with
you because you're my mom i love you i
want to hang out with you because i love
you and you're someone that i believe is
great to have in my life
i love it i [ __ ] love it
i love it keep doing you don't change i
love everything you are like i can
already see it anything you're gonna
ever [ __ ] put your hand in it's gonna
be bad [ __ ] a badass thank you i love it
um and you i'll close it out i know this
is gonna close it up uh you also have a
mentorship yeah so if anyone listening
right now really connects and vibes with
this dude hit up matt vincent he'll
steal he'll help you steer whatever it
is you're trying to steer to um thank
you so much matt yeah [ __ ] love you
dude you guys are so proud of you so
inspired by you so motivated by you
nothing but love man same same tons for
both you guys man you're not allowed to
say that on our podcast bro it's about
you
thank you
all right guys anything you want to say
nope every time god dang it all right
thank you so much for watching
love you guys as well and we'll see you
next week